well our Sports correspondent Rob Harris
joins me now Rob we watch the game
together England 12 goals now in four
games this tournament eight different
players to have scored but importantly
tonight finally Harry Kane was on the
scoring sheet yeah Kelly be desperate to
score on this tournament had those
injury concerns earlier on but he felt
he was already ready Prime to be able to
score just like his slow start at Euro
2020 and here he's finally off the
market of course he's been providing
those assists as well but it was an
all-round team performance after that
perhaps flat start where there were
those mistakes that were creepy in to
England's game they survived those and
really overpowered Senegal after that
and particularly excelling Jude battling
of a teenager still but he's really
announcing himself on the world stage
and him talking about Jordan Hennis as
well at the other end of the age bracket
saying actually the Liverpool midfielder
is a bit underrated technically but he's
been important in this journey to the
quarterfinals and it really is an
impressive run for gara Southgate side
now three clean sheets their opponents
on Saturday here France they did concede
tonight in their game as they beat
Poland than 3-1 but England perhaps will
have a bit of confidence with the talent
and depth of players at Gareth
southgate's disposal that they can
potentially beat the world champions uh
a word on one player who wasn't
featuring tonight Raheem Sterling left
out of the squad Gareth Southgate said
before and for personal reasons we
understand he's flown home what more do
you know about what's going on with
Raheem Sterling yeah it's a very
distressing incident for Rahim Sterling
his family back in England their home
was attacked by armed Intruders in the
last day and Bracken Sterling felt very
distressed and concerned about that and
felt he needed to fly back to his family
we understand he's on his way back home
now but remains fully committed to
England and could well return to Qatar
during the week if his family's safety
is assured he's the second player to
leave the England Camp Ben White also
left due to personal family reasons as
well okay we wish Raheem Sterling and
his family uh all the best and hope he
is able to make it out to the tournament
um one small dampener only a small one
England's defensive unit back did look
fragile at times particularly in the
first half hour in the first half now
France who they will face on Sunday
particularly the world's most valuable
player Killian mbappe are really on form
he scored two screamers tonight and so
the England Unit will have to be working
together as one uh almost a week from
today they've got the best part of six
days to rest recuperate and regather and
then I'll be back here on Saturday for
that quarterfinal match against the
current world cup holders France